okay before we say goodbye let's play a
quick round of truth or dare
all right someone can ask me anything or
dare me to do anything who wants to go
first how about all right name out of
the hat tammy nicholas tammy nicholas
are you here get down here
[Applause]
hi hi tammy how are you i have no idea
what's going to happen
i love spontaneity great druther dare
truth
you want drew yes okay okay
um so have you ever fallen in love with
or had an affection towards one of your
co-hosts
they're co-stars oh yeah
i mean i dated justin long he was a
co-star i've dated him on and off for
years
um i mean i've been in the business
since i was a kid yeah he's like the
person i ended up like having a crush on
and then having like a long-term
relationship with
um
but uh yeah and just so you know people
in the industry definitely uh do get
together you're like out in the middle
of nowhere for months at a time and
you're playing lovers and you're totally
wrapped up in it yes so anyone who says
they haven't are liar right
i'm sorry
and uh luke wilson yeah i dated luke
wilson you're very long time yeah he's a
great guy
um and um
yeah
great i think people i literally can't
remember right now
fun fact i did make a list to try and
remember and then left it at danny
devito's house because i was making like
notes for our production meeting on the
other side of it so if you ever do make
a list don't leave it at danny devito's
house
[Applause]
well you know i will always keep it real
with you guys and i gotta tell you this
show is a space to laugh be honest pour
your heart out learn love and just
let's try to figure this out together
let's try to get to that happiness and
hope and all of it thank you so much for
choosing to spend your time with us we
make this show for you so take it with
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you